okay thank you i am ocean-born gifting
to
smack my bishop bishops were unsmackable
here
oh okay so raided 10 minutes so yeah
yesterday we i think we played raided
blitz
i feel like addfost has got to be one of
the most like prepared
traxxar players in the world because
there's not too many people that just
specialize in
uh in such an opening
okay so i've learned a little bit from
yesterday
let's not waste too much time the first
few moves
so i'm not playing a stafford allowing
knight g5 oh no i'm getting forked
so the key is to take here this is
all opening theory
um yeah if king takes f2 i would have
taken and had some more fun
so here i have to play queen e7
and then yesterday i actually i figured
out the the theory is to play
d5 and then i think it's d5 knight d4
that was pre-moved i don't want to play
this first because bishop here
so i first want to defend against bishop
here
and play oh yeah this move is very
clever
allowing the knight to maybe come back
eventually
so i think i'm supposed to take with
queen
but i didn't mind the position like
taking this pawn
i get the center pawns
and then what happened yesterday
i think bishop g4
we had this exact line yesterday i think
queen f1
so i'm down a rook in the bishop
however
it's okay i think hopefully
oh yeah so yesterday bishop b5 check was
played
king f8 b3
oh look i have to play king fade again
we're going into the same thing i
haven't put it on youtube yet but
yesterday we had b3
queen c5 bishop a3
and like i i kind of blundered my queen
but then after
check here i made it
unfortunately white's winning after king
e1
in this line so um
b3 okay so i'm not gonna play queen c5
even though
it worked yesterday it's not gonna work
again
uh this is clearly a threat so i'll play
king g8
getting off the diagonal trying to win
the night also getting off this
alignment and now
now maybe we'll have a fun position
i think i'm guaranteed to win the night
so
only going to be down a rook
that's a crazy position
these things are scattered like king on
f2 and knight here bishop here
there's potential to attack from
multiple directions
also rook fade is now an idea
the sea pawns hanging
i'm pretty sure white's objectively
better here because i did check the
engine very briefly yesterday and again
it gave like plus two i think after b3
okay i'm gonna avoid looking at chat too
because
some people might know know things
better than me
so people can openly discuss moves in
chat and i
i won't be looking
but it's good to see okay ifos is
thinking here
so no more relying on prep
bishop a3 i think was probably the best
move
and i'll probably queen c7
just getting away from the attack
and having some idea of queen b6 to hit
the king
also targeting c2
maybe i should have considered 94 but
it's a type of thing i don't want to
give whites time to move the king back
and
then have ideas of queen f7
so i only want to play in 84 when
there's a clear like forcing sequence
i guess with the bishop here now i can't
play rook f8
without losing a rook but okay there's
more things to celebrate
this thing what are my resources
basically these are the main resources
and i think like even though white
should be objectively better it's just
easier to play for black
but add foss has time to think
and contemplate c4
well c4 is cool so defends the bishop
kind of
one thing i could maybe try and trap the
bishop
answers this move and oh but then b5
i could also trap the rook could also
take the knight
i'm still down there wrecking the bishop
what is this
c4 is resourceful for white because now
if i play queen
b6 or c5 oh but then i could take
i'm just confused i also have knight i
should calculate 94 kg 192.
wait why is that not possible oh my
queen was attacked
yeah wait knight e4
also king three so if king
one i made king e3 it just looks fun
yeah so if here i should have started by
calculating this
here here i win the queen a king e3
might be the only move
is there a mate
um the pawns defend the knights it's
like a pawn nightcube
knight um let's see two in that line
okay i'm feeling good
just a matter of how i want to continue
let's start with this
at some point i might have to take time
to
capture the night
what the position i feel like this is
typical troxer physician though
and this is crazy even for me
okay so if i
i should have thought i had a bit more
take on i want to take here but then
queen f7
so i think i just i take on h8
i'll be down a rook but life goes on
there's no back rank
trauma there's a funny line d3 knight c2
mate
and d3 looks like such a natural move
too
if i'm controlling all these squares
not controlling the square though
but all the other square is like i'm
controlling around the king
this is just the ones getaway square
okay i'm really curious to analyze this
afterwards
because i'm not sure if black is
objectively better here but
it still looks fun to play
so knight c3
it does allow me to play this and win
the bishop
oh but d5 is a bit tender
yeah d5 holds things together too
[Music]
i wonder if i can play this move
there's a crazy line
which i kind of want to go for
not sure though okay so queen b6
95 knight ring b6 is the type of move i
can play right away too and just
the intuitive
wait a minute here here it takes
i was concerned about 95 i have
the king's on d3 in that line so here
here it takes takes here
here here
king here might be some
per pet
man this is so confusing
could also start by taking me no
so i want to play this move to threaten
this with my idea but then
takes and then my knights hanging
this is so confusing
oh there's a funny line
okay i'm gonna play this
because there's actually a funny line
i was rejecting i should
let white make the next move first
before i explain anything
this is so crazy
okay so white has a few different
captures here
but there is there's a lot of things for
white to worry about too
[Music]
between mostly because the king's on e3
and there is there's at least one forced
me threat
have to watch time though
of course i'm threatening like so many
discoveries like taking
these are the two main threats taking in
queen h6
i'm going to start calculating
man the lines are so confusing to
calculate even
all these disguise there's so many
options there's like so many branches
thankfully it's white's move and white
has to be the one to calculate here
and then i can just respond
but depending what white does i might i
might use like most of my time on the
next move
it's turning into a a blitz
very soon gonna turn into a bullet maybe
there's no increment either
such a funny position
thanks for subbing now eleanor
okay
i'm feeling i'm feeling the adrenaline
okay so this is a funny line i
initially thought was good for white i
think i'm mating by force after another
5.
so knight f5 if king takes it's maiden
one
and then king d3 queen d4 king c2 queen
d2 king b1
oh it's not mating because knight c3
knight c3
doe
a deer
i think i still go for that line though
it looks really really close to being
really good
i'll beat down a rook but okay let's
have some fun
so it's double check slightly
reminiscent of yesterday
let's only move i mean this is legal but
uh it gets mated
now check
yeah i initially i thought this was
force mate
but okay here here here
where's my knockout blow
is there a knockout
oh there's a funny move knight e3
which but then queen c1
oh i have bishop e2 oh that's a funny
move too
threatening bishop d3
and threatening the queen
yeah the fact i'm down a rook doesn't
matter too much given the rooks aren't
too involved
okay i think it's uh it's
pretty cleanly winning now
um might have a chance for some beauty
mate
there's 92 king c2
[Music]
the thing is i don't want to like take
on c4 and then walk into a pin like that
so let's play knight d4
i'm returning to the center
and now knight d2 is probably a bigger
threat because it would force king b2
i take with double check king c3
queen d2 king takes knight
wait it's so confusing
okay let's go for the check
oh it's a discovered it's a dork it's a
discovered fork
um it's also wait
where's my force mate because if i play
this or is roxy
two it's still winning
i wanna meet by force
you can see three oh it's made in two
here here mate it's such a weird like
meeting
configuration and if here it's mate
uh i have a blind spot that the bishop
is now hanging
okay a very weird type of
pattern don't see every day
okay uh good game i fast this was a
higher quality game than
like much bigger fight than yesterday
uh i've
i've i'm beginning to enjoy the tractor
more and more
cause it's a cool line even for
like lower rated players um
because a lot of players will go into
this like knight g5
and if you want to have a lot of fun as
black
and not play as stafford um
this is a nice alternative i guess
and yeah king like a lot of players like
if you look at this on the chest
wait chess
okay most people know to play king f1
but a lot of players will take and then
get into a lot of trouble after
knight takes e4 um
and we went into like the line that was
played is supposedly the refutation
oh should we rematch should we rematch
before i analyze
i would be down for one rematch one more
i didn't analyze at all oh
okay we're doing one more